tantissima bruttissima anche se questa
volta non siamo alle 3 di notte però
giocheremo dei giochi spavento
alcuni se ne avete consigliati voi
perché giocheremo al della ndrina noi
giocheremo a granny versione barbie non
lavorati vedere come sarà lavoro
sistematico che farò sarà pauroso di
tutti penso che sarà il primo che
proviamo
il gioco di it il pagliaccio horror andy
mettetevi pure comodi e lasciate un mi
piace se volete altri gameplay horrors
questo video raggiunge i 10 mila p mi
piace ne faremo altri scriveteci nei
commenti quali altri giochi volete che
proviamo
si vedrà se il commento più votato di
sempre quella gioia che la volta del
rina infatti mi comodi protesi la
cioccolata calda
il pandoro e panettone ma anche il
torrone e cioccolato
ok il primo gioco in cui giocheremo e it
pennywise il paglia 5 tantissimo quindi
c'è la modalità relax in cui non può
vederti c'è più luce niente sangue
niente cose horror ma noi siamo più
coraggiosi la modalità fantasma la
conoscete modalità bambino un po più
lentamente si insegue per un breve
periodo come possiamo iniziare proprio
con questa sfida e un po più facile
sono nella mia camera farina
qua c'è un foglio vediamo quando
leggerai questa lettera io potrei essere
già morta sono stata rapita da hit ci ha
bloccati in questa casa e inseguiti come
fossimo giocattoli lui mangia le nostre
paure giorno dopo giorno
vai via da qui non cercarmi ho disegnato
la e finisce usa finisce così perché
probabilmente isla già presa e chi è
questa persona questa c'era l'intro
all'inizio dove spiegava che bill stava
cercando beverly che era sparita
misteriosamente essi sospetta nel
ritorno di hit dopo 27 anni quindi è la
vera storia di trovare possibile in
cucina per il questionario la corrente
elettrica
ok
quindi andiamo in cucina dove sarà equa
di qua
paura questa casa inquietanti viva
questa ok ho trovato la cucina a un
coltello vabbè
apprendo adesso il frigorifero però
questa cosa e fusina iacolo ok ma che
c'entra il frigorifero ha detto ok
abbiamo messo la luce ma non è che vuoi
controllare la spesa ma ti sembra il
momento non so perché c'è qualcosa di
interessante
ok prendiamo i coltello così si poteva
difendere sarà meglio chiuso con il
frigorifero è la gitana lì tanto lui
ancora non c'è
continua così a questo rumore comunicato
riguardo aiuta ma perché scappo così
lentamente che reso promotore di là lo
avete visto che brutto ma cosa che mi
sembra un po ingrassato comunque ti fa e
l'ho pure era un po più magro forse
fantasmi troppo lenta capitale quattro
quindi vuol dire che abbiamo cinque
giorni come ingressi
[Musica]
che paura questa casa qui siamo di nuovo
in cucina ma aperto guarda c'è una
striscia di sangue 4 piano salire una
striscia di sangue allora c'è qualcuno
dietro attento davvero c'è qualcuno che
si muove un rabbia che si fa clicca a
uso ok
lui è buono anche tu non lo so ma vabbè
abbiamo sconfitto il ragno
beh schifo ma cosa ha perso molto sangue
di trovare una cassetta al pronto
soccorso per rapporti per il poliziotto
gli verrà in parte
non so come si fa a buttare ci sono il
rumore si sta avvicinando lo scarico nel
mio letto dice è giusto in tempo
se il corto stranamente rho che
aspettate stan smith questo nostro blog
a nando i passi
ragno comunque ho finora questo mi sa
che il gioco più horror di sì scrivete
nei commenti secondo voi qual è il più
horror di tutti il più inquietante di
tutti
mamma mia che ansia
si riceva una porta asse di legno mi
serve un piede di porco ok
e dobbiamo anche trovare la cassetta la7
pronto soccorso per aiutare di un piano
di sopra che ripetono
ecco il piede sportivo così almeno mole
questo schifo di ragno ma non me lo fa
preda ecco ok mi hanno preso piede di
porco ma si fa sopra non so cosa ci stia
a sopra ho un po di paura di scoprirlo
ma anche paura di scoprire cosa c'è
dentro questo sta anche se abbiamo porta
a posto avremo la porta aiuto
non c'è niente ma che così maestà mara
mara si passa mara nella casa di it sta
piangendo c'è un fondo si ciao bill so
chi sei e perché sei qui io ti aiuterò
uccisero segni wise se libererai la mia
foto sono stata rinchiusa qui sono molto
tempo portami un ragno un topo ed infine
illumina damiani maledizione bollino è
finita qua questo è il gioco veramente
più horror di tutti però ci aiuterà a
uccidere penny wise modelli l'unica che
sa come fare paragoni far salire su
vediamo che il giorno giorno io a tra
poco mamma mia
dopo alla fine del video vedremo il
replay al rallentatore tutti i momenti
più spaventosi quindi il mio fino alla
fine perché era molto libertà
perché io ero a casa ma non girare lì no
ma lentissimo gira a destra c'è la testa
mamma mia sarà interessante sociali
sociali sub sub sub su questo aiuto ma
non pensate come badanti 0
coloriamo sposiamo c'è un codice qua ci
vuole la password per aprire questa
porta un anziano prova ad aprire
quest'altra il banco c'è qualcosa qui
sono dei fiammiferi prendere perché il
naso ma e li voleva sia alla luce che
qui guarda qui posso nascondere tra
nella vasca da bagno zona no no questo
succede quando ti nasconde ago pista che
non è vicino ok mamma mia
diamo nell'altra porta quadrati
che sarà chiusa violante ha aperto un
altro bagno a un interessante ma quando
vai via se iniziassi dopo a dieta forse
c'è qualcosa dietro
forse sotto deve morire cassettini qui
ok proprio ora che arrivi da un momento
all'altro la brinca quest'altra ti puoi
abbassare solida spina sono tanti tra
sconti o che mi sono rannicchiata parte
non vivere qua aperto l'altra porta
geniere gente prove dove dico allora
forse dovevo venire qua solo per
prendere i fiammiferi può essere e anche
trovare dovrei tornare qua hamas quale
però io devo prima devo si può portare i
fiammiferi alla bambina indemoniata dice
a samara si aveva bisogno della luce poi
non so come portarlo in radio perché
l'abbiamo lasciata
correva leggere la nostra sinistra
sinistra il labirinto questa casa non
entrare qui no non ne farei
ok però devo prendere il rancore e alla
cucina se non sbagliate così almeno
depist chiamo un pochettino non ci non
ci segue da tempo che così torna
indietro da lui la morte morosa ok lui
non c'è devo andare dal giudice in un
atto che hanno superiore sala da pranzo
cucina dei saiyan se siamo in un'altra
stanza nasconditi cosa sta arrivando
eh sì è che mi sentii bassi
[Musica]
se n'è andato per fortuna adesso c'e
dietro a me sembra che sta proprio
arrivando a bergamo sto di no ma 61 sono
i passi ma non c'è niente
ok lo dici tu scusa ma non per altro
solo due giorni ci rimette anche se ce
la faremo
allora dentro non abbiamo trovato noi
siamo
[Musica]
ok allora
proviamo a trovare qualche altro indizio
qui c'è qualcosa
questo ci può servire no non miri solo
costanza era stata quella con tutte le
braccia
ok allora dovrebbe stare da questa parte
qui
ho capito ho capito
[Musica]
stamane vicino ciao
ma come si fa a qui questo è uscita per
scappare porta del seminterrato si può
andare
la porta è chiusa da via maledizione ok
dunque questo e quel il gioco più
paurosi tutti pensano qui abbiamo
giocato forse no era più avanti e la
porta che abbiamo se non sbaglio
dovrebbe essere pollicino qua c'era il
poliziotto forse forse mi sto
confondendo del tutto
eccole qui sono incastonati scampo a
scappare ero vicinissimo primo giorno da
il proviamo a dare rapidamente dalla
marea ti ricordi dove dovrebbe stare da
questa parte si sa porta il seminterrato
quindi vai a sinistra tutta dritto
ancora dritto c è paura
no no no no più avanti più avanti
praticamente era dall'altra parte
abbiamo fatto tutto il giro eccola qui
era questa sì che è tifosissima ci sono
le candidate ad esso ok usa abbiamo
acceso le candele pare si va a casa lo
trovare il traguardo in parte no ok
caschi ma questo caso il topo lo abbiamo
visto da qualche facevano i topi né gli
angolini è però non lo so ragno
non saprei come prendere il topo
costituiremo trovarci qui un'altra a
quando siamo mai entrati
no è una trappola per topi come ferro di
un idea o no
sentiva t2 tnas con di quasi sulla
scogliera no non lo so io provo odio
prodotto
e arrivato il momento di le ndrine
ciao
vediamo se più inquietante di se la roma
se l'arto prima stanza ok modalità
facile avrebbe quindi penso che devi
recuperare a 91 liberi hanno questi
libri sia produciamo anche qua è molto
inquietante fa sembra più nei
sotterranei più che una casa i
sotterranei di un castello e sulla
modalità facile difficilissimo anche i
muove appunto finito una sola vita
guarda verso la vita provo io adesso ma
è troppo strano che ti dà solo una vita
voi siete riusciti a completare questo
gioco exit dice fa quindi no non ex ma
ok deve prima trovare tutti i libri per
poter uscire quindi troviamo i liberi 9
la mia anche inquietante come tutto buio
dovevate un labirinto questo modo non si
vede niente
ma io prima ho trovato tutte le porte
dall'altra parte bene divisa ma li e li
guarda ma 9 è un cosa lei aiuta ma per
senso la sinistra non si strappa come
fatto tutto crediamo perché aveva prese
ok ok abbiamo un libro sarà impossibile
trovarne tra 7 e un labirinto stai
volando per ora gnorante di quindi alla
guarderò anche il primo libro immagino
non lo so ancora il primo libro qui ma i
partiti non ho qualche vita in più mamma
mia
mentre qua e chi lo sa bloccata
ma le sentenze l'inter in a
ok allora proviamo ad andare da qui e
giriamo tutto a destra che a sinistra
andiamo dove ci può ora che spunti voi
all'improvviso le moto dritto qua non
labirinto davvero facili può abbassare
no
[Musica]
andrea non è chiuso questo ma c'è un app
osta
616 incastrare un vicolo cieco aiuto
land riva a sorpresa non mi ha presto
preso si trasforma in un ragno
ok ora abbiamo granny barbie che ci
avete consigliato voi a me sembra
gravissimo piazza casa che credito
sovrano in barbie da tantissima
bruttissima però l'altra volta green di
babbo natale vi è piaciuto tantissimo
bellino ci sta guardando un po male
allora di quelli tra facile comensoli
dove magari è meno inquietante visto che
barbiero vediamo vediamo la sala camera
guardate i muri leopardati devo dire che
la camera è molto più carina
beh si è più luminosa anche anche se
questo quadro un po ad esso stesso
qualcosa questo quadro abbiamo la porta
è tutto rosa che anche un po troppo rosa
direi
vediamo il bagno google bagno ho fatto
nuovo fatto premi barbie a il gabinetto
d'oro la vasca da bagno d'oro c'è un
pezzo di quadro qui prende volo sarà una
barbie prendiamo il quadro ok a me
sembra un pezzo di vizi o di una bambola
e andiamo a vedere qui siamo la porta
oddio quest'origine piano non far cadere
la lampada ok c'è un altro pezzo di
quadro la sopra dobbiamo tornare a
prenderlo poi no del piero
finora non si e degli studi molto bene
insieme anche sentito però il problema è
che allora andiamo a portare subito il
quadro il pezzo di quadro sfondiamo
tutto che faccia bene si sono posati di
fans ma anche incredibile
anche sul tetto perché proviamo a
scendere e si è sentito a tanta
inquietante arriva e speriamo di no e
allora qui ci abbassiamo spongebob
ovunque
tutto bello colorato poi tu fai
inquietantissimo si muove però queste
diverse da will wright ai bidoni di coca
cola in volto ben ok abbiamo appoggiato
abbiamo permesso
andiamo a vedere che cosa c'è in garage
ci sarà la macchina rosa e prima viene
la barbie è tutto rosa losilla è brutta
gli interni sono rosa è bruttissima solo
il sedile rosa sono un sedile sono
uscita sono fatti vivi a fare tre di
loro due
ciò che facciamo l'ultimo giorno vediamo
se ce la caviamo
ci stiamo svegliando le sei la nostra
bellissima cameretta rosa leopard up
io però vorrei vedere meglio credi c'è
una trappola qui attenzione
maledetta vorrei vederla meglio come hai
visto cosa ha detto mario de qua vicino
[Musica]
guarda il pavimento è fatto di di barbie
il piccolo ma la gente di barbie hanno
fatto cadere lavoro siamo non se ne
accorgano là dentro rilasciate mi piace
se volete altri episodi cui giochiamo
giochi offrono giochi strani
consigliateci nei commenti e scriveteci
nei commenti anzi importanti nel
sondaggio si quale gioco vi ha fatto più
paura tra i tre premi wise land riina o
grandi barche e ora vediamo il replay
dei momenti più spaventoso 4 caselline
scribili care per vedere i nostri gli
altri video